[Music]
[Applause]
it was on this date in 1984 Kevin McHale
closed lines Kurt Rambis game four NBA
finals and I'm not sure was Kevin McHale
not called for a foul in that that would
have been a playoff foul yeah Paulie I'm
watching the play now it's chaos because
when Rambis gets hit he gets hit by
Gerald Henderson first and then Rambis
uh
Michael's come from back the back and
hooks him around the neck but the ref is
being blinded he can't see it I don't
see a foul call well
I'm reading an article here it says uh
in 1984 however it may be hard to
believe but only Mikhail received a foul
for his action oh okay yeah yeah
that was playoff basketball back then
Jeff right that was a regular foul
yeah there wasn't I don't I don't know
when the flagrant foul came in to being
but I just my first one that I remember
is when uh I was in assistant with the
Knicks and John Stark's clothesline
Scottie Pippen in a similar Manner and I
think that was a flagrant foul but you
were not getting thrown out for that
back then that was like bad boy slap on
the wrist put the ball back in play
both teams are playing the we get no
respect card which one has a better
argument in this series
one's a top
s in the West
and have you know was in in first place
since December and the other team beat
the two best records in basketball on
the way to the final so I think both
have gotten the appropriate amount of uh
credit for what they've been able to
accomplish which is immense they've done
great things and I think this uh David
no one respects us it may play well in
their own individual locker rooms but I
don't think it's true
is this a pivotal game three tomorrow
night
I think they always are I think
uh you know the split by Miami uh what a
great fourth quarter they played and
the two days off lets both teams gather
and re-energize and recharge
and I think Denver has played really
good basketball
for six of the eight quarters I thought
they had a bad first
or really like they had two bad fourth
quarters I mean really like bad fourth
quarters in both games and their start
in game two uh was probably very
unacceptable to Michael Malone
I know you have to know your team as a
coach but Michael Malone calling out his
team for a lackluster performance
especially on defense
um that's not Eric spolster his uh
Playbook but it is Michael Malone uh are
you surprised at all with that attack
that approached by him
no I've always wondered what we want out
of coaches when you ask them a question
do you want an honest response or do you
want like him saying we tried hard
because if you go back and you watch the
game there were
a lot too many possessions that were
either uh lacked intelligent
process or didn't give enough effort to
get the job done so I'm not sure exactly
what we want him to say there like
yeah fouling two three-point Shooters
love that
um we got to keep doing that I I don't
know what we want from these coaches he
could talk in more cliches he could talk
more you know around the issues but I
think
Denver and their players are used to his
directness and I think okay uh if you
have the right best players the the
right best players want to be talked to
in a straightforward manner well if he
was going to be honest and then he
actually called out Michael Porter Jr
then I would have said that's a coach
who's being honest because Michael
Porter played horribly in that game
you're kind of lumping everybody in that
we didn't play It's Like We we played a
hundred percent seventy percent of the
time and uh that's why we lost this game
and then you have Eric Spoelstra where
Ramona Shelburne is saying hey you know
uh I'm simplifying this but are you
trying to make uh Joker more of a scorer
than a passer and he basically said it's
an untrained eye uh Reggie Miller said
the same thing what Ramona said you know
you you want to keep him from passing
the ball getting everybody involved in
the was that a crazy question by Ramona
to Eric Spoelstra
no and I think if you watch the game uh
it would tell you that they gave less
help now that doesn't mean they want him
to score but I think when you watch what
their priorities are when you're playing
against a great player and I don't care
who the great player is
you can't take away everything but you
need to take away something and it
usually starts with taking away easy
baskets created either for yourself or
others and the free throws and I think
he had a couple of great passes to
Gordon on cuts that led directly to easy
baskets but other than that
because they made him play a lot of
one-on-one he had to score up and
through really sound defense and so
I know what Eric is saying like you you
don't have it in your power to just say
we're going to make him a score but
I think Ramona's question was spot on in
that they did take away
one of his great strengths
yeah if those players hit five of those
shots then he's got a triple double or
at least close to it and then we're not
even talking about this but they they
made those shots tougher on the rest of
the Nuggets therefore he didn't get
those assists that he normally gets
we're talking to Jeff Van Gundy he'll be
on the call with Mike Breen Mark Jackson
game three of the finals that's tomorrow
night at 8 30 Eastern tip off on ABC
what is going on with Kyrie Irving in
Dallas
in what way well the story came out that
he was recruiting LeBron
to come to Dallas if you believe that
um so he doesn't even have a contract
with the Mavs I don't believe but do you
believe that he was trying to recruit
LeBron to the Mavs this past year
I don't I couldn't imagine that because
the fit between donchic Irving and and
James doesn't seem to be like a
a complimentary seamless type of fit so
and I can't imagine LeBron James leaving
the Lakers
um by trade I mean they just went to the
Western Conference Finals he has a son
who's going to play at USC he has
another one who's going to be I think a
junior in high school who's a very fine
player so I can't imagine James
uprooting his family at this point
doesn't make sense to me no I didn't
know if it was a leveraged play on
Kyrie's part or LeBron's part to maybe
get Kyrie to go to the Lakers could you
could you see that
well I could see any I could see it like
the Lakers wanting kind of Kyrie Irving
I mean he's obviously an extremely
talented player now how they would
create the cap room
to be able to sign in to the value that
he'll command
you know that's problematic obviously
but I I could absolutely I mean they've
won a championship together and I think
one thing Irving doesn't get credit for
even in that short stint with Dallas is
that he's able to fit in with other
really good players he fit in with
LeBron James and Cleveland with Don
judge he played off the ball more still
produced at a high level so I think he's
one of those guys who has so much skill
that he can play in many different ways
and always fit in with the really
special players
no half time no free throws you've been
throwing these out when you get bored is
that uh what's going on Jeff
well
somebody said to me I don't agree with
you right and I said sometimes I don't
even agree with myself after much
consideration but
but
can we start smaller let's start smaller
okay let's go to the international rule
on when the ball hits the rim the ball
is live and there's no goaltending once
the ball hits the round I love it you
can knock it away or you can put it in I
think would add a lot of uh really good
athletic play and it would also relieve
the officials from making what's nearly
an impossible call so let's start there
I still don't believe the only guy who
loves free throws is like Mike Bernie he
loves talking about free throws and and
I I always kid him he loves to wax
poetic during free throws about a sob
story that's been overcome but it's
really the extra point of football it's
boring it's like it's time consuming and
so I would like to
um you know take that out of the game
until the last four minutes where
pressure free throws obviously you
wouldn't want to take that away well
wait a minute we move we move the extra
point back in football so why don't we
move the free throw back to the top of
the key
fine now now we're talking okay now
we're talking okay let's do that all
right let's do that or or let's even get
a new line in between the free throw
line and the top of the key or or even
hey let's go for something like usflish
if you if you want to shoot a three you
could get an extra half point I don't
know let's spice it up the free throw
game is boring okay and you can't get
dap at the free throw line we have to do
away with slapping hands if you make the
free throw or miss the free throw
it's a waste of time
agreed and if you missed the free throw
there should be some
point of Shame and humility
yeah so okay all right so we're work
shopping this I I'm fine with uh going
take away offensive goaltending uh free
throws let's move them back no dap at
free throw line and you want to do away
with half time
and and can I add one else sure because
I
I'm on this flopping thing for years it
got better for a while it's regressed
because they've eliminated the
punishment they they used to when they
made a hard stand on it they find uh
players five thousand dollars and they
put them on a list right and for
whatever reason they've gone away from
that I do believe there should be
after evaluation a Scarlet love uh
letter f a fix to offending players
jerseys for a certain amount of time if
it's a game five games but I think there
should be a reminder out there to the
officials Yep this guy's gonna try to
trick you and you're not going to fall
okay how about this we get a little
letter F and then we sew it on your
jersey the Scarlet F and then we see how
many F's you have on your jersey that
season
like the Buckeyes helmets Yeah you know
like yeah yeah Michigan Wolverines yes
okay you know what I like how you're
thinking Dan you should be on the
competition committee well I did say to
the commissioner uh basketball's
positionless so you can't have Rudy
gobert on uh you know one of the first
second or third teams all NBA just
because he's a center get rid of that
and he did I said we need to have a
minimum that you have to play to qualify
for any kind of awards he did that and
the other one was I said you got to get
rid of the carrying it's getting
embarrassing and you know the kids in
grade school in high school are
emulating what they see with the pros uh
Jason Tatum can't dribble a basketball
without carrying the ball Jeff why are
we allowing this
well every year there's these emphasis
and they always start with traveling and
uh caring and they're called for maybe
you know a couple weeks and then
people like you're messing with my game
you know like you know it starts to
impact so they go away from but like if
you watch a hesitation dribble you know
guys going and then they hesitate and
they lift up a little bit you have to
carry the ball like there's you know as
you lift up your hand is going to go
under the ball so the fans the what they
call themselves as purists if they
really wanted to see travels called you
could basically call it travel on every
possession is that what we want same
with carrying I think
it sounds good in theory but actually
implementing it
it would take away and has taken away
and yet the defense is already at such a
huge disadvantage I know that we took we
keep making it harder and harder on the
defense you know very little contacts
allowed and if you let people travel and
carry the ball you know then they are
quote unguard them well you go back to
Allen Iverson
did Iverson create the carry
no he but he was a he was a great
proponent of it like he was good as the
forefather of the carry like that's a
good question like Vlade is to flopping
like I would say who was the first guy
with this like the spin dribble where
they would just like basically cup it
and bring it over like Pearl Monroe
then let's give Earl some credit you
know he's for for that and he started a
great High School in New York City where
underserved children are being taken
care of so I want to give Earl credit
for both things yeah but I don't think
you want credit for bringing the carry
into the game
well again it's such a fine line and I
think this is where
you don't want it to be called by the
letter of the law like travels right so
you mentioned Reggie Miller and if he
was coming off a pin down to his left
he would catch it on his right pivot
foot looking shot
but then if he didn't have shot and he
came to a stop he would go to his left
he would just switch his pivot foot
because he felt more comfortable on his
left a lot of people do that that's like
League wide do we want that called I
think as a lead we have to decide do we
want that called
or don't we because when you
when you say we want travels enforced I
I really don't think we know the total
impact it would have on the flow and
Rhythm of the game okay are there more
travels in an NBA game or holding calls
in an NFL game
there's more holding calls okay yeah and
there's a whole probably on every play
right in the NFL I suspect I would think
yeah it's like the illegal defense or
the defense of three like that's called
like
below once a game and if you watch it
you know like you mentioned Rudy gobert
before you know he's gonna stay in there
until they call it and so yeah I just
think it depends on what we want
what are you going to do the rest of the
day
well we have to go over and do
interviews where Mike asked probing
questions of player tries to bring him
into tears and uh that sounded snarky
Jeff that sounds
reflect on on sad things and so it
brings a tear to my eyes yeah I bet it
does I bet it does yeah and then you
know we last week we played pickleball I
and uh but we sustained an injury Mike
Green play like popped the calf so we're
down a man
um so you know when you get to this age
like maybe what's called lunch or early
dinner you know and then we're gonna
like call it on it you know so
I don't get pickleball I played it once
I don't get it I I you know you know I
don't really really about pickleball
watching it on TV
like I tried to watch it on TV and I'm
like those little dink shots back over
back like I'm like uh
all right you're losing me now like you
know I don't get that it was sort of fun
to play but not as much action as tennis
and I think it's great that people are
not watching on TV on peacock that Jeff
has double beds here so a bed for him
and a bed for his brother and uh or Mike
brand I don't know I don't know the cost
measures there the mothership anymore
I I thought we were going to get through
a whole interview without the mothership
and I'm so glad we didn't but yeah you
know I might invite stand down for a
sleepover I expected a king I got a two
like twins so hey Stan make the trip
down when's the last time you had a
sleepover with your brother
oh
gee I mean when
when I was making no money I went down
and and had to recruit like when he was
in New York so I probably didn't pay him
for uh some crappy place he had in
Yonkers maybe like that would probably
be the last time yeah uh play nice
tomorrow night with Breen okay
yeah well
you know
let's try
Mike is like like he's coming off back
to back Emmy Award wins so he's becoming
a little bit less
um uh what is that called collaborative
he's he's in the Basketball Hall of Fame
Jeff
I know are you yeah no I'm not gonna be
there
you you've contributed to the game
you're a contributor to the game you're
17th NBA Finals come on if Breen can get
in
well I think when you you pose as a
serious thing to eliminate halftime
[Laughter]
thank you Jeff
you got it take care that's uh Jeff Ann
Gundy the mothership a former NBA head
coach
he'll be on the call with Mike Green
Mark Jackson game three tomorrow night 8
30 Eastern on ABC